[Musik]
sebastian bastelt das kinder kult
produkt von ferrero na ja da setzte die
klein glücklichmacher frische milch
brauchte dafür nicht warum der konzern
trotzdem mit der guten zeit werben darf
erfahrt ihr jetzt aber wie viel gutes
von der milch steckt bei kinder
tatsächlich drin
sebastian lege zeigt es am beispiel der
beliebten kinder choco bons die möchte
der produktentwickler ganz nach dem
berühmten vorbild von ferrero nachbauen
die klein glücklichmacher schokolade der
münchen gekehrt
mit kleinen haselnuss stückchen der
weiße kern sie tatsächlich nach milch
aus genau das will ferrero erreichen
dabei bestehen chocobos vor allem aus
viel fett dem perfekten geschmacksträger
für seinen nachbau vermischt sebastian
geschmolzen ist palmöl mit ganz viel
zucker
[Musik]
ja puderzucker und nicht zu wenig sehr
schön süß schmecken durch zucker in
guter form wird die weiße creme im kern
geschmeidig und kam nicht dazu für den
quatsch jetzt fehlt nur noch
magermilchpulver denn frische milch
setzt ferrero in seinen schoko baums
nicht ein
[Musik]
dabei stecken in ihr wirklich gute
inhaltsstoffe vor allem die
spurenelemente kalzium kalium natrium
und magnesium gelten als gesund daneben
sind außerdem milch zucker und milch
fett enthalten welche dieser
bestandteile sind in den schoko bons
denn tatsächlich enthalten
wir schicken das produkt zusammen mit
kinderriegel kinder country kinder happy
hippo und milch schnitte in ein labor
und lassen die menge an spurenelementen
milchfett und milchzucker bestimmen
die gute nachricht in allen untersuchten
produkten stecken durchaus wertvolle
teile aus der milch die spurenelemente
kalzium kalium natrium und magnesium
sind überall noch enthalten
und das sogar in großen mengen in 100
gramm kinder choco bons finde das labor
drei 1000 milligramm kalzium in 100
gramm frischer vollmilch stecken dagegen
nur 125 milligramm kalzium sehr viel
weniger
wir finden aber auch sehr viel milch
zucker und milch fett in den süßigkeiten
viel mehr als in der gleichen menge
frischer vollmilch
grund ist das konzentrierte milchpulver
das problem in dem pulver stecken zwar
viele spurenelemente aber vor allem
milchfett und milchzucker wenn ferrero
auf diese weise milch zusetzt werden die
produkte vor allem eins noch süßer und
noch fetter in den süßigkeiten stecken
also tatsächlich die guten bestandteile
der frischen milch sogar ein großer
menge
doch durch den vielen zucker und das
fett haben sie viel mehr kalorien als
frische milch
[Musik]
1 200 milliliter glas frische vollmilch
kommt auf rund 140 kilokalorien nichts
im vergleich zu schoko bons in 200 gramm
der süßigkeit stecken satte 1000 150
kilokalorien das achtfache
die guten spurenelemente werden zur
nebensache
kinder choco bons bestehen am ende zu 90
prozent aus zucker und fett
die milch dient vor allem dem marketing
[Musik]
für seinen nachbau bringt sebastian die
süße und fettige füllung in die richtige
form gut gekühlt kann sie im nächsten
schritt umhüllen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir brauchen jetzt die schokolade noch
mehr zucker noch mehr fett wie vollmilch
und ein wenig halt bitter schokolade
lässt sebastian auf die richtige
temperatur schmelzen 31 5 reicht noch
nicht ganz aus noch ein bisschen umhören
bei exakt 36 grad hat die schokolade die
richtige temperatur
nur dann wird sie nicht fleckig und
lässt sich gut verarbeiten
ja genau so muss sie aussehen die
silikon formen waren inzwischen lange
genug im tiefkühler gut sieht richtig
gut aus
in einem 34 kessel will sebastian die
bonbons mit schokolade umhüllt rasieren
ist ein ganz üblicher prozess in der
lebensmittelindustrie wo man mehrere
schichten auf ein rundes produkt
aufbringen möchte hier kommt kalte luft
raus
das ist wie ein betonmischer jetzt
kommen unsere kleinen milch eier da rein
vorher ein bisschen schokolade und dann
wird schicht für schicht langsam
aufgetragen nun trifft die flüssige
schokolade auf die festen bomba meyer
damit das gut klappt ist die richtige
temperatur wichtig den bonbons darf es
nicht zu warm werden sonst schmelzen sie
die schokolade dagegen braucht warme
luft sonst wird sie zu schnell fest und
legt sich nicht gleichmäßig um die
füllung
[Musik]
so langsam wird das was diese temperatur
ein bisschen höher fahren damit wir
schokolade vom mantel wieder lösen ohne
an das produkt heften
das gar nicht so einfach eine heikle
geschichte rangiert sebastian die
bonbons nur ein wenig zu lange schmelzen
sie dahin sieht sehr abenteuerlich aus
jetzt müssen wir die oberfläche
stabilisieren das macht sebastian mit
den zusatzstoffen gummi arabicum und
schellack sie sollen für einen schönen
glanz sorgen
fertig ist der nachbau wie hat es denn
nun geklappt
naja den schönheitswettbewerb gewinnen
ich damit nicht aber tranchen ist nicht
so einfach
das endergebnis von sebastian lege
ziemlich durchwachsen
die temperatur war dann doch wohl etwas
zu hoch aber es schmeckt
magermilchpulver viel fett viel zucker
mit braucht nicht schokolade umhüllt die
gehabt stattdessen lockt auf ferreros
kinderprodukten nur die frische milch
die süßen sachen sollen gesünder wirken
als sie sind
[Musik]
wir dürfen nicht aus den augen verlieren
ist ist eine süßigkeit ich sollte sie
wirklich nur selten essen
man darf gerne mal einen schoko gelassen
aber man darf sich nichts davon
versprechen dass ich davon wachse gesund
bin und eine extraportion milch bekomme
umso heikler dass sich ferrero mit
seiner kinder reihe seit jeher auch ein
junger verbraucher und eltern wendet die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who
empfiehlt kindern maximal sechs stück
würfelzucker am tag
dieser wert ist schnell überschritten
beispiel ein kinderriegel enthält schon
vier stück würfelzucker in zwei chocobos
stecken zwei weitere so wenig vernaschen
und schon ist die empfohlene tagesdosis
erreicht
[Musik]
mit hilfe der zutat milch versucht
ferrero seinem süßwaren einen gesunden
anstrich zu geben
tatsächlich steckt in den produkten
milch wenn auch nur in pulverform
doch die eigentlichen hauptbestandteile
werden durch die vielen milch bilder auf
den verpackungen zur nebensache
ein cleverer trick denn ähnlich wie bei
anderen süßigkeiten spielen auch bei
ferrero fett und zucker die hauptrolle
was haltet ihr von den
gesundheitsversprechen auf süßigkeiten
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt denn abonniert die zdf
besser esse und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips
[Musik]
[Applaus]